STEVE: THEY WERE TOO CLOSE.
WE KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE RIGHT
NOW.
LET’S BRING IN DR. MEHMET OZ,
HOST OF THE DR. OZ SHOW.
HE HAS BEEN JOINING US EVERY DAY
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
DR. OZ, IT IS TERRIFIC THAT THE
COMFORT IS NOW IN THE NEW YORK
CITY AREA.
YESTERDAY THEY SAID IT WAS
70,000 TONS OF I LOVE NEW YORK.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO BE SERVING
PEOPLE WHO DON’T HAVE COVID.
HERE’S THE PROBLEM IT.
JUST TAKES ONE CASE OF COVID-19
ON THAT SHIP TO POTENTIALLY TURN
IT INTO SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN CRUISE LINES, DOESN’T IT
IT?
>>
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
BUT THEY ARE PRETTY CAREFUL
ABOUT THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT’S A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF YOU WHO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN PLAY A POSITIVE
ROLE JUST FROM THE VISION HAVING
A NAVY SHIP COME INTO PORT TO
HELP YOU OUT.
IT RAISES MORALE.
AND THERE ARE RISKS NO, QUESTION
ABOUT COVID-19 COME IN.
THEY ARE METICULOUSLY MONITORING
EVERYBODY.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF
SEPARATE FACILITIES FOR COVID-19
PATIENTS AND FOLKS WHO HAVE THE
AILMENT.
ANOTHER FIELD HOSPITAL THAT’S IN
CENTRAL PARK BUILT BY
SAMARITAN’S PURSE THAT’S ONLY
TAKING COVID-19 PATIENTS.
WE ARE PRETTY CAREFUL ABOUT
THIS.
THERE ARE WAYS OF SCREENING IT.
AS SOON AS ANY SYMPTOMS ARE
DEMONSTRATED AT LEAST IN THAT
SETTING CAN YOU RAPIDLY CHANGE
THAT ALL A POSITIVE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
BUT THE BIG ISSUE IS THE
TESTING.
THEY HAVE TO TEST IN THAT
HOSPITAL.
AND THE PRESIDENT SPOKE ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY.
WE HAVE A MILLION TESTS NOW IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S THE SOLUTION THAT ALL OF
US NEED.
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT TESTING,
YOU JUST DON’T KNOW.
SO THE COMMANDER OF THE COMFORT
DOESN’T KNOW.
THE HOSPITAL DOESN’T KNOW.
THE GOVERNORS DON’T KNOW AND THE
PRESIDENT DOESN’T KNOW IF YOU
DON’T TEST PEOPLE ADEQUATELY.
AINSLEY: DR. OZ, IT’S FUN I
COULDN’T MENTIONED THAT THE
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY IN HIS PRESS
BRIEFING HE PULLED OUT ONE OF
HIS RAPID TESTS BEING
DISTRIBUTED STARTING TODAY.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID IF YOU
MISSED IT AT HOME.
>> TODAY WE REACHED HISTORIC
MILESTONE IN OUR WAR AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS.
OVER 1 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
NOW BEEN TESTED.
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY BY
FAR.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
AND TESTED ACCURATELY.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
TODAY, THE UNITED STATES HIT
MORE THAN 1 MILLION SAMPLES
TESTED.
A NUMBER THAT NO OTHER COUNTRY
HAS REACHED.
WE’RE NOW TESTING NEARLY 100,000
SAMPLES A DAY.
ALSO A LEVEL THAT NO OTHER
COUNTRY HAS REACHED.
AINSLEY: DR. OZ, I WANT YOU TO
RESPOND TO THAT ALSO BRIAN
MENTIONED THE MASKS, YOU COULD
SEE WHERE PEOPLE, THE FEVERS ARE
GOING DOWN.
WHY IS THAT IF YOU HAVE
DR. FAUCI SAYING THE PEAK IS
GOING TO BE IN A WEEK OR TWO?
WHAT DO WE BELIEVE?
ARE WE GETTING BETTER?
ARE WE GOING TO SEE A PEAK IN A
WEEK?
>> I THINK BOTH ARE TRUE.
THE REALITY IS THE FEVER COMES
FIRST.
THE PERSON THEN SORT OF
STRUGGLES FOR A COUPLE DAYS.
THEN THEY FINALLY GO TO THE
HOSPITAL IN NEW YORK CITY
BECAUSE THERE IS NO ROOM.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
KEEP YOU OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
WHEN YOU FINALLY GET ADMITTED A
WEEK OR 10 DAYS LATER IT SHOWS
UP A STATISTIC THAT THE GOVERNOR
CAN SHOW AND SAY LISTEN HERE IS
SOME DATA ON HOSPITAL MISSION OR
MORTALITIES ANOTHER WEEK OR TWO
DOWN THE ROAD.
YOU DON’T GO TO THE HOSPITAL AND
DIE GO TO ICU INTUBATED AND
STRUGGLE AND GOD FORBID YOU DIE.
THE NUMBERS MAKE PERFECT SENSE.
MAYBE BRIAN CAN BE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
DEEMOLOGIST GOING FORWARD.
HE IS RIGHT.
WHAT WE SEE IS A SLOW DECLINE OF
THE RISE WE ARE SEEING.
NO LONGER DOUBLE NUMBERS OF THE
HOSPITAL EVERY TWO DAYS IT’S
EVERY SIX DAYS.
THAT SHOULD PEAK NEXT TWO WEEKS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT NUMBER IS
WHAT THE PRESIDENT JUST SAID,
1 MILLION TESTS DONE THAT NUMBER
MEANS WE CAN FINALLY DECIDE IN A
TARGETED WAY EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO.
WE CAN TAKE SNIPER SHOTS AT
PROBLEMS RATHER THAN HAVING TO
BLAST EVERYTHING WITH A SHOTGUN
THAT GIVES US SO MUCH MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THE
PROBLEMS WE ARE FACING.
BRIAN: THAT BOX.
GET THAT BOX OUT GET QUICK
RESULTS DON’T NEED REAGENTS.
HOW DO WE BUILD IMMUNITY IN OUR
SYSTEM TO KILL THE VIRUS EARLY?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
EXAMPLES OF PROGRESS THERE?
>> I WILL GO THROUGH THE RISK.
FOUR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES I WILL
LEAVE IMMUNIZATIONS TO THE SIDE
VERY HAPPY JOHNSON AND JOHNSON
GOT A BIG GOVERNMENT CONTRACT TO
REALLY SCALE THIS UP WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF COMPANIES DOING THIS
GOD BLESS THEM ALL THEY ALL WORK
IN SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAYS.
I AM VERY CONFIDENT SOME OF
THESE WILL PAN OUT NEXT YEAR.
MEANTIME FOUR DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES FIRST THING BUILD UP
INNATE IMMUNE SYSTEM.
COUPLE WAYS OF DOING.
THIS LIST PUT UP ON SCREEN.
FIRST ITEM I’M GOING TO POINT
OUT AND THIS IS CRITICAL THAT
CAN YOU ENHANCE THE IMMUNE
SYSTEM WITH CONVALESCENT PLASMA
THERAPY ANTIBODIES MADE BY
SOMEONE RECOVERED INTO SOMEONE
WHO IS DEATHLY ILL.
THAT SEEMS TO JUMP START THEM.
THERE IS A NICE ARTICLE IN JAMA
BIGGEST MEDICAL JOURNALS FOUR
OUT OF FIVE PATIENTS DID WELL
WITH THIS PROGRAM.
THESE PEOPLE WERE ALL DYING
BASICALLY AND FIFTH PERSON STILL
ALIVE.
THAT’S GOOD NEWS.
INTERESTING HIGH DOSE VITAMIN C
MIGHT PLAY A ROLE HERE.
VITAMIN C HELPS SHORTEN THE
DURATION OF A COMMON COLD.
PROBABLY WORTH CONSIDERING NEW
YORK HOSPITAL AND OTHER
FACILITIES STILL TESTING IT.
JURY STILL OUT.
GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS LIST.
ALL ON FOXNEWS.COM.
PUT IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA FEEDS AS
WELL.
100 DIFFERENT IDEAS OUT THERE
THAT ARE BEING TRIED.
NEXT UP, YOU WANT TO PREVENT THE
VIRUS.
IF YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM IS NOT
STRONG ENOUGH.
YOU DON’T WANT THE VIRUS TO GET
INTO THE CELL.
HOW DO YOU BLOCK IT FROM GETTING
THAT’S WHERE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
PLAYS A ROLE.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT A
LOT.
ANTIMALARIAL DRUG.
PLAYS A ROLE.
I CORRESPONDED WITH THE
PHYSICIAN IN FRANCE LEADING THE
TRIALS.
THEY WILL HAVE 500 PATIENTS ON
COMBINATION WITH AZITHROMYCIN C
PACK THIS WEEK IF HE COULD HE
WOULD ADD ZINC.
HIGH DOSE ZINC COULD POTENT
UNITED STATES THE ACTION.
THAT’S SOMETHING CAN YOU DO AT
HOME, ACTUALLY.
TAKE A LOW DOSE IF YOU DESIRE.
DON’T HAVE EVIDENCE.
HIGH DOSE IF YOU ARE ILL MIGHT
MAKE SENSE.
IF YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM CAN’T
CATCH AND IT PENETRATES INTO
YOUR CELLS, THEN THE QUESTION IS
HOW YOU BLOCK ITS REPLICATION?
HOW DO YOU STOP IT FROM DOING
DAMAGE?
THERE IS A BUNCH REMDESIVIR IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE.
PROMISING THERAPIES.
SOME OF THEM HAVE NOT SHOWN
THESE ARE DESIGNED FOR OTHER
ILLNESSES LIKE HIV AND EBOLA AND
BEING UTILIZED IN MORE
AGGRESSIVE FASHION IN TRIALS.
THEY SHOULD WORK.
BLOCK THE OVERRESPONSE OF OUR
INFLAMMATORY SYSTEM.
THE COMPLEMENT STORM SO TO SPEAK
WHERE THE BODY CAN’T KEEP UP
WITH THE VIRUS AND TWO
MEDICATIONS PUT ON HERE WHICH
ARE BOTH STILL EXPERIMENTAL A
BUNCH OF OTHERS THAT WORK IN
THIS AREA.
REMEMBER, IF WE HAVE A DRUG THAT
WORKS WITH PEOPLE HAVE HORRIBLE
INFECTIONS OR BAD CANCERS TO
BLOCK THE OVERRESPONSE OF THE
BODY.
YOU COULD USE THOSE SAME DRUGS
FOR CORONAVIRUS FOR COVID-19.
THAT’S OUR HOPE.
ONE LAST IDEA THAT I QUICKLY RAN
BY LOW SAR TAN WHICH IS A
MEDICATION THAT’S A BLOOD
PRESSURE MEDICATION IT WORKS AS
THE SAME RECEPTOR THAT THIS
VIRUS USES TO SNEAK INTO YOUR
CELLS.
THE JURY IS STILL OUT.
WE DON’T WANT PEOPLE GOING OFF
THOSE MEDS MAY HELP YOU FROM
BLOCKING THE VIRUS FROM COME IN.
THOSE TRIALS.
FDA APPROVED PRODUCTS HAVE TO
SHOW THEY WORK.
THIS MIGHT BE AN OPPORTUNITY AS
WELL.
STEVE: SURE, SO DR. OZ, THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY IS IS LOOKING
AT ALL THESE VARIOUS DRUGS.
I KNOW THEY USED SOME SUPER
COMPUTERS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT DRUGGINGS MIGHT WORK WITH
THIS PARTICULAR VERSION OF
COVID-19.
STEVE: DOES EVERY DOCTOR KNOW
THESE POTENTIAL DRUGS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HELP THEIR PATIENT?
>> NO.
CATEGORICALLY NOT.
ONE DRUG GOTTEN MINE SHARE OF.
I KNOW THIS BECAUSE I HAVE
TALKED TO SO MANY DOCTORS IN SO
MANY STATES HIGH TKROBGS I
DIDN’T CHLOROQUINE WHEN COMBINED
WITH AZITHROMYCIN.
ELEVATED CONVERSATION POINT BY
DISCUSSIONS BY OUR PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND MEDICAL COMMUNITY
EXPECTS THEY ARE PROBABLY SAFE
ENOUGH WE ARE NOT DOING ANY HARM
AND THE GOVERNOR OF KANSAS TOLD
ME RECENTLY HE SAID YOU GO TO
WAR WITH THE ARMY FLINT
FIREFIGHTERS UNION AND THIS IS
ALL WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
BUT SOME OF THESE OTHER PRODUCTS
HAVE BEEN USED CLINICALLY IN
OTHER.
LOW SAR TAN FAMILY OF DRUGS,
BLOOD PRESSURE DRUGS.
THOSE DRUGS COULD BE RAPIDLY
TRANSITIONED OVER BECAUSE
DOCTORS KNOW HOW TO USE THEM AND
USE THEM SAFELY.
IF THERE IS ANY CLUE THEY MAY BE
BENEFICIAL AND THE RIGHT PATIENT
START TO EXPERIMENT.
WHAT DR. FAUCI SAID IS RIGHT.
YOU WANT TO SIMULTANEOUSLY TEST
THESE.
WHEN THE IT PRESIDENT INSISTED
CLINICAL TESTING IN THE MEANTIME
PUSHED THE FDA TO APPROVE THESE
PRODUCTS FOR DOCTORS TO
PRESCRIBE THAT WAS THE RIGHT
MOVE.
TRUST THAT THEY MIGHT WORK.
VERIFY THAT THEY WORK WITH
CLINICAL TRIALS.
IN THE MEANTIME DON’T HOLD THE
DOCTORS BACK.
DON’T TIE THE HANDS OF DOCTORS
FOR DOING THE MOST FOR THEIR
PATIENTS.
IF YOU APPARENT AND GET
COVID-19, IT IS WORTH ASKING
YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT ANY OF THE
PRODUCTS ON THIS LIST.
ESPECIALLY HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
WE DON’T KNOW FOR SURE IF THE
CHLOROQUINE IS EFFECTIVE.
YOU MIGHT TRY IT.
AINSLEY: DR. OZ, BRIAN WAS
INTERVIEWING A GIRL IN HER 20’S
WHO HAD IT.
SHE WAS SO FRUSTRATED CALLED THE
HOTLINE WAITED AN HOUR AND 4 445
MINUTES.
THEN THEY TOLD HER THEY WOULD
CALL HER BACK WITH THE TEST.
SHE CALLED AGAIN.
ON HOLD FOR A WHILE.
AND THEN THEY SAID YOU NEED TO
CALL YOUR PHYSICIAN AND GET A
TEST.
SHE CALLED HER PHYSICIAN AND SHE
SAID NO, THAT’S NOT WHAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
I KNOW WE ARE FIGURING THIS OUT
RIGHT NOW AND A LOT OF UNKNOWNS.
WHERE WILL WOULD HE BE AT A
POINT IN THE COUNTRY WE HAVE ALL
THE DRUGS AND MASKS WE NEED AND
WE HAVE ALL THE SUPPLIES FOR THE
HOSPITALS?
WE HAVE THE VENTILATORS.
WHEN WILL WE GET TO THAT POINT?
>> WELL, YOU WERE KIND ENOUGH TO
ASK MY QUESTION OF THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY BECAUSE IT’S ALL
DRIVEN BY TESTING.
I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE WHY
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
RIGHT NOW IF I ORDER A TEST AND
THIS IS TRUE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
I CAN PROBABLY WAIT FIVE OR SIX
DAYS TO GET THE RESULT BACK.
IMAGINE GOING TO A HOSPITAL AS A
PATIENT.
YOU ARE NOT SURE, HAVE A FEVER
AND COUGH AND FEEL TIRED.
CLASSIC SIGNS BUT YOU DON’T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS.
YOU GET ADMITTED THEY ORDER THE
TEST.
FOR FIVE TO SEVEN DAYS YOU STAY
IN ISOLATION ROOM WITH ALL THE
NURSING WASTING CAPS, GOWNS,
MASKS BECAUSE IT TURNS OUT YOU
DIDN’T HAVE COVID-19.
BECAUSE MOST OF THE TIME THE
TEST COMES BACK NEGATIVE.
ALL THOSE RESOURCES THROWN AWAY
BECAUSE WE DIDN’T HAVE A TEST.
LIKEWISE, OUR ABILITY TO TARGET
PEOPLE AND MAKE SURE THE RIGHT
ONES ARE GIVEN PRIORITY TO GET
TO THE ICU OR GET INTUBATED IS
WASTING WHEN WE DON’T KNOW FOR
SURE WHAT WE’RE DEALING WITH
ONCE WE HAVE THE TESTING, ALL
THE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES BECOME
AUGMENTED BECAUSE WE WILL USE
OUR RESOURCES MORE EFFICIENTLY.
THE VENTILATOR, I DO BELIEVE BY
THE MIDDLE OF APRIL WE WILL HAVE
G.M. AND OTHER COMPANIES MAKING
ENOUGH THAT THAT PROBLEM GOES
AWAY.
BRIAN: I HOPE.
SO SO, YOU HAVE TALKED MORE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
AND YOU WANT TO GET THE RESULT
OF THIS STUDY.
SO, IS ONE WAY TO GET THE RESULT
OF THIS STUDY IF I CAN SAY THIS
EFFECTIVELY IS THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON IT NOW FOR WHATEVER IT IS
LUPUS OR WITH EVERYTHING ELSE,
CAN YOU FIND OUT HOW THIS VIRUS
IS ACTING IN THEM AND QUICKLY
GET THEIR RECORD FROM MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID BECAUSE IT’S PAID
FOR BY THEM AND SEE HOW IT’S
ACTING?
GET THE RESULTS OF THAT STUDY
AND SEE IF IT CAN BE MASS
PRODUCED FROM COAST TO COAST?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT IS SUCH A BRILLIANT IDEA.
THE KHAO*EUBZ ACTUALLY DID IT.
THE REASON THEY BEGAN USING THIS
DRUG AS PART OF THEIR ROUTINE IN
CHINA IS THEY LOOKED AT A
HOSPITAL THAT HAD A VERY BIG
VOLUME OF CASES.
IT TURNS OUT THAT NONE OF THE
PATIENTS WHO WERE ON THE
CHLOROQUINE FOR THEIR LUPUS OR
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS WHICH IS
THE REASON YOU WOULD BE ON IT
GOT COVID-19 AND CONVERSELY NONE
ON IT GOT.
ONE OF THEM WAS MEDICATION USE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE KEY CLUES
THAT GOT THEM MOVING FORWARD ON
MAKING THIS PART OF THEIR
FORMULA SO TO SPEAK.
THAT IS A WONDERFUL CONCEPT.
CMS -- SEEMA VERMA COULD DO THIS
IMMEDIATELY.
RAPIDLY RECALL CHECK TO SEE IF
HAVING PROTECTIVE EFFECT THAT
WOULD GIVE THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
COMFORT THAT THEY WEREN’T
OVERSTRETCHING BY REACTING TO A
BUNCH OF CASE REPORTS AND LARGE
GROUPS OF PATIENTS BEING DATA
COLLECTED AS OPPOSED TO
TRADITIONAL RANDOMIZED TRIAL
MORE COMFORTABLE ACTING ON.
STEVE: THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING US AN UPDATE ON THINGS
THAT ARE GOING ON ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF MEDICINE RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE PATIENTS IN THE STATES OF
LOUISIANA AND MICHIGAN AND NEW
JERSEY.
IT LOCKS LIKE THOSE ARE THE
STATES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED NEXT.